If you want to disguise
your blowgun, you can also use
camouflage that matches
the environment you're in.
[Captions by Mike R. at Y Translator]
Hey guys. I'm Nate.
Welcome back to the workshop.
Today, we're gonna take
a look at another DIY weapon.
We're going to be building a
blowgun out of a cereal box.
Here's what we're gonna need
for this build: a cereal box, of course,
preferably one of the taller ones.
This is an 18-ounce box of cereal.
We've got some tape,
some paper clips, Post-It notes,
bamboo skewers,
a few straws and a glue gun.
We'll also be using some scissors,
a ruler and a razor blade.
The first step is to take
the  cereal out of the box.
We actually just need the
cardboard that the box is made of,
so put the cereal aside
and  use it another time.
With our box nice and empty, we now want
to break it down so it's all one flat sheet.
Our cereal box is now open,
it's flat, and we can cut out
the pieces that we need from
these flat sheets of cardboard.
We want to cut out a
rectangle that's three inches wide
and as long as we can get in
one unbent piece of cardboard.
To start, let's remove the
flaps around this larger triangle.
With the flaps removed, we can
measure off a three-inch width,
and we'll cut that rectangle
out of this piece of cardboard.
We now need to score lines
into it and fold it into a triangle.
We want to measure off four equal
sized portions within this three inch strip.
So, let's mark off
every three-quarter inches,
and score the cardboard at that width.
When I say score, what I mean
is that we'll take the razor blade,
we'll line the ruler up on those lines,
and we'll drag the razor
blade across the cardboard,
but not hard enough to cut all the way through.
We only want the cut to go about
halfway through the cardboard,
and that will let us bend the
cardboard perfectly along the lines.
We can see that there's clearly
a mark in the cardboard,
but it hasn't separated into two pieces.
It's all still very much one piece.
Let's do that for the other
two lines, as well.
It's now easy to see that we have
four equal portions of our cardboard,
and we now want to fold
along each of those lines
folding into the shiny printed side.
Use the ruler to sort of push along the
edge so it's all folding at the same time.
You can see how nicely it
folds along the spot
where I've scored the cardboard.
We now have our cardboard that's been
scored and folded all the way around.
So, now we need to glue it together
but we're not gonna go for the square,
we're actually going to
overlap two of the pieces
and fold it into a triangular-prism shape.
With the cardboard folded, we'll use
the hot-glue gun to keep it closed.
If you don't have access to a hot-glue gun,
you can use
strong tape for this step, as well.
We now have our triangular-prism shape
that will work as our blowgun.
Let's add a few features that will make
our blowgun function a little bit nicer.
Let's grab one of our paper clips
and bend the very end of it
at about a 90º angle.
Using some tape, we now want
to secure this paper clip to the
bottom of one side of the prism.
This is going to act as
sort of a safety guard
that makes it so when
we use our blow darts,
they can only go into the gun
but they can't come back out.
I could probably use
scotch tape for this step.
But you know here at the King of Random,
we do love electrical tape.
Now that's attached.
And let's actually add another
layer of tape beyond that,
not to hold the paper clip down,
but as sort of a mouth guard.
This is cardboard, and if we
put our mouth on it too much,
it's gonna end up getting soggy.
The waterproof nature of the
tape will help prevent it
from deforming with extended use.
The basic blowgun is built, and now
we need some darts that go with it.
Let's grab our Post-It notes
and some bamboo skewers.
Peel off a single Post-It
note and try to roll
it into a fairly tight cone shape.
Now, Post-It notes are sticky,
but they're not so sticky that
they'll hold themselves
when they're tightly coiled.
So let's add a bit of
clear tape onto this cone.
Now, we need to get this cone
shape to fit into this blowgun.
They're obviously not the same size.
But what we can do is, using the end
that doesn't have a paper clip on it,
press the cone down into the
blowgun until it's filling all the way
to the edges of our triangle.
Using a pen, mark off where
the paper meets the cardboard tube.
Now, we'll use our pair of scissors
to cut off the excess paper.
That should give us a cone
with a triangle profile
that fits perfectly into our blowgun.
A little cone of paper isn't  gonna
travel very far or very fast though,
and that's where the
bamboo skewers come in.
Let's cut off a piece about two inches long
from the pointy end of our bamboo skewer.
There should be a small hole
in the tip of the cone.
But if it's not quite big enough
for the bamboo skewer to fit through.
Just widen it a little bit
with a pair of scissors,
fit the bamboo skewer until most of it
is protruding out of the
front of the paper cone,
and then secure it in place
with some more tape.
There's one dart.
Let's make three more.
We've got some darts made
and we've got a blowgun made,
let's test one of these darts
out and see if it's working.
So, we've got our little guard
that will stop our dart
from coming out of the gun backwards,
but we should be able to just push
the dart right into the gun past that guard.
Let's see if our blowgun can
drive one of these little darts
into this piece of foam core board.
Boom!
Look at that.
That stabbed right through it.
Beautiful. So, we know that works.
Our darts are just sort of laying around,
so, let's build a mechanism
that lets us attach them
to the side of our gun
for easy reloading.
We've got a lot of cereal box left,
let's cut out another rectangle
from one of these smaller pieces.
This one 2 1/4 inches wide
by 3 inches long.
We now want to cut this
rectangle into three equal strips,
each one 3/4 inches wide
and 3 inches long.
With our three strips cut out,
we now want to score and
fold them the same way that
we did with the blowgun body.
Before we glue these
three pieces closed, though,
we want to add a small
section of drinking straw
into the corner of each one.
Let's cut off three pieces of
drinking straw that match
the width of these –
3/4 of an inch.
Of course, you don't have
to do different colors,
but I have them available and I do
like having different colors of things.
Let's use a small dab of
hot glue in the center crease
to attach our straw pieces.
Remember that they will be attached.
And then fold it into
a complete triangle, so,
we don't want to glue them
with the cardboard wide open.
We want to glue it with the
cardboard already pinched at an angle.
Once the straw is attached to the center
piece, we can use a little bit more glue
to glue these two outside tabs together.
We can now attach these three triangles
to the outside of the body of the gun.
Position them so that the
straw is on the outside portion
and not one of the inside corners.
We can now have one dart loaded
into the barrel of our gun
and three additional darts
pressed into the straws
on the side of those prisms
that we just added.
Now, when we're ready to reload,
we can just grab another dart
and fit it into the back of the gun.
At this point, our blowgun is
functional, but it looks pretty bland.
It's just cardboard colored.
So, let's get some tape and see
if we can't decorate this thing a bit.
I think that's looking quite a bit more
stylish, but I don't want to quite finish yet.
There's a few more design
elements that I want to add on.
When Grant showed you how to build
the laser-assisted PVC blowgun,
he had a laser pointer added on,
and I think we can do the same thing
to take this up to another level.
Here's the laser pointer that we will be
mounting to the side of this blowgun.
It's got a nice, bright green dot.
Should show up nicely even
in pretty light conditions.
A couple of side-mounted supports
should help keep the laser pointer
nicely centered on the blowgun.
Our cereal box blowgun
is looking quite good.
It's decorated. It can
hold three extra darts.
It has a laser sight on it.
At this point, what we need is
a target to shoot it at,
something more interesting than
a blank piece of foam core board.
I've printed out this picture of a zombie,
and we're gonna try mounting that
to a piece of this board
so we have something
more specific to aim at.
Beautiful.
I'll call him Bob,
Bob the Zombie.
Bob the Zombie has volunteered
to be our blowdart target –
and by volunteered,
I mean he can't complain
because he's a printed-out
piece of paper.
Let's try hanging Bob up and see
if we can shoot his lack of brains out.
Whew! A lot of power.
Maybe too much power.
Couldn't control it.
Ha!
Right in the face.
Take that Bob.
Hit the board.
Missed the zombie.
Yeah!
Hand!
Stabbed him in the hand.
Eyeball!
That'll take out even a zombie, I think.
Ha!
His heart was still beating –
well, now it wouldn't be.
Good work.
Brainless shot.
It's not 100% accurate because
our darts are made out of
paper and bamboo,
but it has a laser on it.
I think the intimidation factor
is the most important part.
Hey, guys,
thanks for watching.
If you're not a subscriber yet,
just hit the bomb to get in the club.
If you missed our last video
or want to watch it again,
just click up here at the top.
Click down there if you
want to see what the Internet
thinks that you should watch next.
That's it for now.
Have fun, be safe,
and see you tomorrow.